okay today I'm going to talk to you
about purity we're gonna see what purity
means in chemistry we're gonna have a
look at a few different examples and
we're also going to see how we can use
experiments to see if a substance is
pure or impure so in chemistry purity
means every substance completely pure it
is made completely of a single element
or completely of a single compound so
what we're gonna do is going to look at
example few different substances so
let's imagine we've got our mininum now
this particular sample value mininum can
you see is made only of one element
there's no other elements in there
whatsoever so therefore because it's
only made of one particular element we
could say that this aluminium is pure
now this could also apply to compound so
for example here we have water now even
though we have two different types of
atom because there's only one type of
compound present h2o only we could say
that we've got pure water here so we can
security could mean all of one type of
element or all of one type of compound
so this is also a pure substance now
it's a bit different when we get to here
here we can see an example of steel now
steel is made of carbon and so a carbon
and iron so it's called an alloy there's
two different and there's basically a
mixture of different elements because
there's a mixture of different elements
we describe this as being impure impure
where's it got more than one thing now
an example another example of an impure
substance would be the air because the
air that we breathe contains nitrogen it
contains oxygen it contains carbon
dioxide and some other gases as well so
that's impure because we have a mixture
of different substances two different
elements or different compounds so we
can actually use in experiments or use
experiments in order to find out
to find out if a substance is pure in
them so let's say we've got three
substances let's say substance a has a
melting point so look at the melting
point of each of these substances have
660 degrees C so let's say we have
substance B has a melting point of
exactly zero degrees C and let's say
substance C has a melting point of 1368
to 1300 and 72 degrees C now the reason
why we could tell that substance see is
the impure substance is pure substances
have a very definite and exact melting
point they sharply specific sharp
melting point that melts at exactly that
temperature whereas impure substances
have a range of melting points that's
because essentially they're a mixture of
different things different elements so
as a result they have a range of melting
points so from this experiment because I
could see this one is the one with the
range of melting points I can tell that
this one is my impure substance so just
to summarize in chemistry purity is
about a substance consisting consisting
of either one type of element or one
type of compound if you have a mixture
of elements or mixture of compounds it
is described as impure and to find two
experimental II find out if your surface
is pure impure you see its melting point
if it's got a very definite and exact
melting point its pure if it's got a
range of melting points its impure thank
you